la fiscalía de perú inició la sexta
investigación preliminar contra el
presidente pedro castillo para la
fiscalía el mandatario sería líder de
una organización criminal y junto a su
ministro general alvarado habrían
direccionado licitaciones y obras para
que algunas empresas ganen contratados
con el estado peruano sin reunir los
requisitos exigidos por ley y según
señala el ministerio público les
beneficiaron entregando ingentes sumas
de dinero mientras tanto la fiscalía
evalúa abrir una séptima investigación
contra el mandatario por obstrucción a
la justicia y encubrimiento al frustrar
la detención de su cuñada jennifer
paredes cuando la fiscalía allanó el
palacio de gobierno al respecto al
mandatario señaló que sacaran todo para
seguir golpeando a su familia pero no le
doblegarán y afirmó que el caso de su
cuñada jennifer paredes forma parte de
la vida política del perú y confía en
que saldrá adelante pedro casi o también
rechazó el proceso de acusación que le
sigue el congreso de perú por presunta
traición a la patria y hablando del
parlamento algunos congresistas
presentaron una moción para que el
primer ministro aníbal torres
al congreso los legisladores exigirán
explicaciones porque hace unas horas el
primer ministro invocada organizaciones
sociales a tomar acciones violentas
contra la oposición en el congreso y los
ciudadanos que critican al gobierno de
pedro castillo mientras tanto el
parlamento prepara una moción de
interpelación contra el ministro general
varado por estar supuestamente
involucrado en actos de corrupción
difícil momento para el entorno
presidencial la defensa del mandatario
espera que su cuñada jennifer paredes no
complique más las cosas en el
interrogatorio que rinde ante la
fiscalía paredes se encuentra en
detención preliminar por 15 días